c'est ici dans cette ancienne carrière
de sable que les ossements de daniel
bonnet ont été retrouvé le 19 décembre
dernier
daniel bonnet soixante dix huit ans
habitait semur en auxois en côte d'or
seul et sans enfant la retraitée n'avait
plus donné signe de vie depuis le 20
avril
c'est son infirmière qui avait signalé
sa disparition
l'infirmière donc est venu je crois le
soir elle avait l'été la fermière
il y avait les qu'elle n'était pas la
belle dès leur sortie et je crois que
les revenus le lendemain matin
ne la voyant pas leur c'est lt à l'abri
la dernière preuve de daniel en vie
remonte au 19 avril dans une banque de
semur en auxois
après huit mois de disparition son corps
est finalement retrouvé près de montbard
soit 20 km plus loin pour ses amis
impossible que daniel ci soit rendu
toute seule elle a bon pas de voiture
elle ne conduisait plus elle ne pouvait
plus conduire
elle avait des difficultés de marche
donc pour elle le savait de venir de
chez elles jusqu'à chez moi c'était déjà
pénible comme elle à montbard je suis
appelé c'est pour l'heure de nombreuses
questions restent sans réponse
la première comment le corps de la
victime at il pu se retrouver ici à 20
kilomètres de son domicile
car des bonnets vivait seul et n'avait
pas de voiture en revanche selon
plusieurs témoins elle était une adepte
de l'auto stop alors aurait-elle fait
une mauvaise rencontre ou at elle
simplement chuté accidentellement
les enquêteurs n'écartent aucune piste
un appel à témoins a été lancé afin de
reconstituer l'emploi du temps de la
victime avant sa disparition